[Musique]
délégué départemental du modem yvelinois
à l'époque jean baptiste à monique 28
ans est devenue maire de villepreux en
juin dernier aujourd'hui il est
président du modem 78 il est l'invité de
cet entretien politique bonjour jean
baptiste à monique bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous c'est votre premier
mandat donc en tant que maire et vous
auriez dû si la situation sanitaire le
permettaient adresser vos voeux à la
population
alors quel message déjà vous souhaitez
faire passer à vos habitants they have
aux habitants pour 2021
effectivement je pense qu'on vit tous
qu'on soit à nouveau mais où installé
depuis plus longtemps un début de mandat
assez particulier en raison du contexte
sanitaire notre quotidien au jeu devenu
la gestion de crise il faut quand même
le dire
le message mois que j'ai pu adresser à
l'ensemble de mes concitoyens vis le
président est aussi au service de la
ville parce qu'évidemment nous n'avons
pas organisé de grandes cérémonies des
jeunes et pour les habitants du pour le
personnel c'est un message d'espoir la
campagne de vaccination débute on sait
que elle tâtonne que ça va prendre du
temps le temps que les doses de vaccin
sont enchaînés dans les centres du
département mais il faut garder espoir
il faut être solidaire fait pour faire
vivre cette entraide qui caractérise
aussi à villepreux et puis surtout
continuer à se projeter vers l'avant
essayez de sortir un peu la tête de
l'eau du quotidien et du marasme ambiant
et puis porter les projets choix que
c'est ce qu'ils attendent de nous au
moment de votre élection vous aviez dit
justement vouloir en raison de cette
crise sanitaire accompagner les acteurs
de terrain créé est de nouvelles
solidarités locales aussi quel retour
vous faites sur ses premiers mois et sur
les actions vous avez pu mener la
première chose qu'on a décidé de faire
et je crois que c'était important c'est
de lancer une grande campagne de
recensement pour identifier les
personnes fragiles d'une érable désolé
de la commune nous avons eu plus de 200
un retour c'est à dire que avant notre
arrivée le ccsa d'identifier une petite
centaine de personnes aujourd'hui nous
en sommes à près de 300 ce qui montre
aussi qu'il y ait de nouveaux besoins
qui s'expriment en raison du contexte
sanitaire et de la crise économique et
sociale qui est présente et qui
continuera les prochaines semaines et
éventuellement aussi les prochaines
années donc cela nous a permis aussi
d'identifier les personnes
et puis maintenant de développer des
actions première d'entre elles c'est est
de développer le plan villepreux
ensemble avec les élus avec les agents
de la commune avec des bénévoles ce qui
vous permet de garder
un d'appeler les gens de prendre contact
de passer les voir de faire du portage
de repas quand cela est nécessaire de
les emmener faire leurs courses
donc on a essayé de faire vivre cette
entraide justement locales aussi avec le
ccrs développer des aides financières
pour les personnes les plus fragiles on
a avancé sur la question des violences
intrafamiliales parce que ça c'est une
malheureuse tendance qui évolue à la
hausse sur l'ensemble du territoire
national et villepreux n'est pas épargné
notamment depuis le confinement et puis
même après avec le déconfinement on
remarque au ce de ce type de violences
donc on accompagne des personnes non
identifiées ont travaillé avec notre
partenaire
il faut faire vivre cette insularité je
crois que c'est important c'était
l'objet d'ailleurs si vous me permettez
de la rose et je sais vous avez venir
vous avez fait une conférence des
solidarités s'était basé hier la veille
de cet enregistrement exactement ça
c'est une initiative locale qu'on
souhaitait porter on l'avait annoncé
pendant la campagne
indépendamment d'ailleurs du contexte du
contexte sanitaire et de la crise que
nous traversons aujourd'hui alors
évidemment ça fait d'autant plus sens
aujourd'hui
cette conférence de solidarité qu'est ce
que c'est c'est et c'était effectivement
le temps des échanges que nous avons eus
le premier temps des charges que nous
avons eu hier c'est de réunir l'ensemble
des acteurs de la ville qui oeuvrent de
près ou de loin dans le domaine de la
solidarité et d'action sociale on a eu
des associations on a eu le département
on a eu 50 ans on a eu à l'institut de
promotion de la santé
on a eu dès le collège le lycée on a eu
des représentants de parents d'élèves on
a eu vraiment tous les acteurs de la
ville qui sont concernés et on a décidé
de travailler autour de quatre
thématiques que sont les précarités le
logement le handicap et les mobilisation
solidaire parce que justement il y à il
ya ce tissu fort de bénévoles sur la
ligne qui nous faut encourager et aider
moi je crois vraiment que seul on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas tout donc
l'objectif c'était de créer les
synergies
on avait une quarantaine de participants
et je suis ravi de voir que l'ensemble
des acteurs présents sont d'accord pour
avancer ensemble donc maintenant on va
essayer de construire à la fois pour le
présent mais aussi pour l'avenir
pour innover aussi socialement et
inventer de nouvelles sonorités pour
répondre aux besoins de nos concitoyens
présents donc le prochain rendez vous
autour de cette conférence des
solidarités aura lieu quand courant
février mars
on va avoir des ateliers maintenant par
thématique
chaque chaque association en tout cas
chaque partenaire pourra se mettre dans
un ou plusieurs ateliers pour participer
activement et on va progresser comme ça
et cheminer ensemble pour définir un
plan d'action pour la ville de lille
prône si on se projette un peu sur la
durée du mandat quels sont les grands
projets que vous allez commencer initiée
sur 2021 alors certains d'entre eux ont
déjà commencé en tout cas dans la sueur
les premiers étages de la fusée et ce
sera aussi l'objet du conseil municipal
que nous tenons ce soir vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir que nous allons ouvrir début
février une nouvelle école l'école
thomas pesquet donc il était prévu c'est
le sens aussi de ce qui nous a été
communiqué par par l'académie
l'inspection académique que l'école
jacques gillet du village ferme ses
portes
or nous sommes très attachés au village
et à la vie au village et donc nous ne
voulons pas que cette école reste close
dès que rien ne soit prévu derrière donc
dans des projets c'est de transformer
cette école jacques gillet en école des
arts de la musique en centre en fait
associatif et culturel à haute valeur
ajoutée ce qui permettra aussi de mettre
de la vie dans ce village ça c'est un
grand projet nous budgétons les études
sur 2021 et nous délibérerons lundi soir
pour demander justement une aide au
financement de ses études à la région
ile-de-france où vous répondant à un
appel à candidature qui s'appelle
réhabiliter plutôt de construire et ça
c'est vraiment notre philosophie
ce qui me permet de faire le lien avec
un autre grand projet la révision du
plan local d'urbanisme pour protéger
justement notre environnement protéger
notre patrimoine et être dans une
logique d'optimisation foncier bâti
communal
plutôt que d'être dans la construction
et dans l'état allemand urbain nous
avons cet objectif de zéro
artificialisation le net que nous
voulons voir inscrire au pmu nous
voulons largement moins construire
largement moins densifier ce qui a été
fait auparavant pouvait se comprendre
mais aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
logique différente quand je vois les
objectifs de construction de logements
qui était prévu au schéma directeur
régional de france
on nous prévoyait 30 logements maximum
par an et plus actuel donner la
possibilité d'aller bien au delà
moi aujourd'hui je ne souhaite pas faire
ça je souhaite maîtriser l'évolution
urbaine et démographique de la ville
tout en répondant et ça il faut il faut
le souligner il faut le dire il faut
l'expliquer tout en répondant
à nos obligations et cerib logement
social car je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui la
commune de wimereux et à 10 7% et qu'il
vous faut atteindre 25% à horizon 2025
sur la prochaine triennal c'est à dire
que nous avons une centaine de logements
à construire
vous parlez des logements parlons
d'urbanisme juste quelques instants les
les projets des projets tels le central
park qui avait été initié par l'ancien
maire avec environ 250 logements qui a
été mis en suspens ne reviendra pas sur
la table par exemple
sinon il ne reviendra pas sur la table
et ça c'est un engagement que je le
prends et je le dis très clairement ce
projet là ne reviendra pas sur la table
il y a un projet qui est bien connu qui
est un projet d'aménagement sur lequel
nous sommes engagés qui doit avoir lieu
qui doit prendre place sur l'ancien
gymnase du collège est ce qu'on appelle
à villepreux un peu plus trivialement
leur bulle du collage donc celui ci
devrait être honoré nous avons nous
allons en revanche menée et ça ça avait
été très clair pendant notre campagne
nous l'avions dit mener une réflexion
sur le quartier de la pointe à l'ange
il a dans cet aménagement là où nous
avons notre bureau de poste là où nous
avons des commerces
nous voulons rendre cette entrée de
ville beaucoup plus qualitative en
partenariat d'ailleurs avec la ville des
clés sous bois et l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines avec un beau
projet celui d'implanter une maison de
service public en france service et je
sais que les clayes-sous-bois la dcri
soit mon collègue philippe guillen est
plutôt partant sur cette idée donc c'est
un portage politique une fois 2 donc des
projets d'aménagement oui mais ce n'est
pas des projets d'aménagement pour
comment dire pourra faire venir
davantage d'habitants je crois que si
nous voulons garantir une qualité de
service aux habitants de la ville
n'avons plus les moyens aujourd'hui à
villepreux de construire densifier
davantage
en revanche là où nous développerons
certains programmes ce sera pour
répondre aux besoins qui s'expriment
aujourd'hui en termes de logement de
toutes les parties de la population qui
ont certaines difficultés qui ont des
besoins de logement et puis pour
conduire des projets comme l'école
jacques gillet comme une maison de
service public et comme aussi un espace
de coworking en tient lieu
je crois qu'aujourd'hui le télétravail
est vraiment un sujet parce que j'ai
d'actualité surtout en cette période de
crise sanitaire par d'urbanisme
d'infrastructures en termes économiques
la commune de villepreux n'est pas
particulièrement
doté d'une grande activité économique
c'est à dire que les ressources ne sont
pas non plus enfin qu elle est un petit
peu la politique que vous allez mettre
en place et essayer d'attirer néanmoins
quelques groupes et sur quel endroit et
quels types de groupes économiques
et puis sinon est ce qu'il y aura un
recours à la hausse d'une fiscalité
éventuellement pour pallier à la crise
actuelle
alors je vous confirme une chose c'est
effectivement que nous sommes parmi en
tout cas les communes de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines
une des communes voire même la commune
aujourd'hui qui a beaucoup moins de
recettes fiscales en raison de son
pauvre sa pauvre activités économiques
sur le territoire
moi je pense que c'est pas une fatalité
donc ça c'est une réflexion nous menons
nous la menons à deux niveaux vous avez
parlé de faire venir des entreprises
ça c'est quelque chose auquel nous
réfléchissons notamment des entreprises
qui pourraient être sur une économie un
peu plus vertueuse je pense au
développement durable je pense au
recyclage
je pense aussi à nos agriculteurs avec
qui nous travaillons essayer de refaire
vivre une économie locale de proximité
du quotidien avec des circuits courts
avec des produits locaux avec de
l'économie sociale et solidaire toutes
ces choses là sont des choses évidemment
que le cul que nous envisageons je pense
aussi que en tout cas pour répondre à
vos questions non il n'y aura pas
d'augmentation de la fiscalité sur le
mandat ça je me suis engagé les impôts
locaux un restaurant au taux actuel et
c'est pour ça que nous ouvrons
aujourd'hui nous travaillons à trouver
de nouveaux modes de financement
aujourd'hui les projets que nous
souhaitons mener s'inscrivent dans des
logiques partenariat là que ce soit avec
le département que ce soit avec
l'agglomération ce serait que la région
ile de france avec l'état et donc nous
sommes et ça c'est quelque chose que
j'ai bien expliqué à la fois l'équipe
municipale et aux services de la ville
de lait cru dans une logique de
chasseurs de subvention de chasseurs
belle si je prie merci puis remet ainsi
c'est à dire que nous voulons vraiment
trouver des financements et trouver
l'argent quelque part si je parle un peu
trivialement là où il est pour pouvoir
porter nos projets mais c'est vrai qu'il
va falloir être très attentif à la
situation
nous avons une situation d'endettement
qui tout à fait correct en revanche les
pargneaux net a fondu comme neige au sol
l'année qu'ovide aura eu quelques
impacts sur la commune mais globalement
la situation financière est saine et
stable
à nous d'être vigilants les prochaines
années et à nous dégager de dégager des
marges de manoeuvre pour pouvoir mener
les projets pour lesquels les présidents
nous ont fait confiance
merci beaucoup jean baptiste à monique
d'avoir été avec nous pour cet entretien
politique et on se retrouve très bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]